so welcome to council of geeks we threw
this one together as quickly as we were
comfortable doing because a whole mess
of spiderman kind of just happened all
over the internet
so i'm kind of glad we're actually doing
this a few days after the initial
announcement because
it's allowed
the dust to settle a little bit and some
things to get confirmed because the
initial announcement of marvel getting
to use spiderman
if you left it at just that sentence
most fans would be ecstatic
but there's a little bit more to the
case than that there is more to the case
than that because sony still has it
and sony is still making their own movie
right
although
they have brought kevin feige on board
to produce which is
uh at least a sense that they that they
seem to understand that they don't know
what they're doing with spider-man and
they're going please you guys who know
what you're doing give us a hand we'll
let you use them just give us a hand
yeah what's still unknown as far as the
solo spider-man movie which is coming
out in 2017 how much input will they
have into the creative side the casting
the hiring of the scriptwriter the
hiring of the director probably in very
broad story strokes and probably in
casting that might be about it but
they've got to have at least that
because even though sony has their solo
movie he's going to appear in a marvel
cinematic universe
film first right chances are now which
brings us to how will he be used
everyone seems to
at this point be assuming that it's
going to be civil war
that's the most logical place to
introduce him
he was a very
crucial part of the of the source
material the civil war comic the movie
is not going to be like that comic and i
can't imagine his role being anything
like that no well it can't be because
let's not forget they're not making
civil war they're making captain america
civil war so it's never going to be
spider-man focused right and the other
thing about inserting him into civil war
is that why he was important to that
story sort of what he represented right
doesn't exist in the marvel cinematic
universe which is the secret identity
thing right because it was such a big
deal that he sided with registration and
revealed his identity but the marvel
cinematic universe nobody's got a secret
identity right all these people are
known and they're also far enough along
on civil war it's going to start filming
in two months maybe i think april is
when they start to fight at most they're
gonna be able to tack him on there they
don't even if they wanted to they don't
have time to restructure that whole
movie to integrate him more heavily and
there are other possibilities because
that's not the only marvel cinematic
universe maybe coming out
um that they would have time to get him
into it has to be it has to be one of
five movies before his movie is
scheduled to come out in july of 2017.
there are five movies before that well
some of those are basically already shot
the post the final post-credits sequence
with the avengers in the shawarma
restaurant was filmed the day of the
hollywood premiere two days before that
movie came out okay
in mainstream okay so maybe they can
give them a post-credit stinger i don't
think that would happen maybe it also
wouldn't surprise me if that did happen
okay movie's still three months out they
could do it so that's a possibility um
here's what not too many people are
talking about doctor strange
those two are a great team up because of
how different they are um they're always
fun to see a team up
i can't see that
spider-man showing up in doctor
strange's first film where we need to
introduce this character and sell him
on his own merits i i can't see
spider-man would be a distraction yeah
and i don't think in a sequel possibly
here's an idea that i
don't think is gonna happen all of the
marvel netflix shows
are set in new york yep
spider-man's a new york hero yep i think
it would be awesome
to either introduce or integrate him
into those netflix shows or at least
failing that at least build him as a
reference point because
you can't tell me he's going on in the
same city as these other people and they
don't know who he is i don't think it'll
happen in daredevil because
i think that would be more of a
distraction again it's
he is the type of character who just by
his nature he's going to suck some of
the oxygen out of the room when he's on
screen a little bit and i don't think
you want to detract away from the
characters
he could show up in aka jessica jones
because she is a character who if done
right is sort of the almost normal
person she does have superheroes but
she's almost the normal in the world of
the gods or her talking to spider-man
would be an interesting situation i
could see that but it also might just
generate buzz for the show depending on
how quickly they get casting done if
they get someone who's not a huge name
they can put in the contract appearances
in the netflix show which you know that
sort of contracting money is the reason
that we're not gonna see
tony stark or even hawkeye show up in
the netflix show even though it's all in
the same right world one of the movies
that we haven't talked about is
guardians of the galaxy too and we're
assuming that spider-man is probably not
going to appear don't think so it does
i did hear some there was the
interesting idea though
of the venom symbiote is an alien
thing
this does open the door that venom could
be introduced whether or not it's the
venom that we
associate that the sort of same image
but that
alien quality that symbiote could
potentially show up in a marvel studios
project and guardians of the galaxy is
the one where it could yeah
oh i hadn't even thought of that one uh
andrew garfield is out that's confirmed
and the word is and this seems pretty
reliable that they're looking at young
like legitimately young not another 30
year old to play teen but a legitimate
teen
which
bums me out slightly
because the only version of peter parker
we've gotten up to this point has been
the teenage version
and i we've had that five movies now i
graduate he got out of high school in
the first spider-man yes but then
but then he's in college
and then the third one i know
technically he was an adult but all the
drama it was still teenage drama right
so i still consider that to be the
teenage version of spider-man we haven't
gotten
adult spread which is actually my
preferred spider-man the guy who has a
more or less stable home life and who
but who goes out and does this thing
because that tends to be the um
the less melodramatic spider-man the
more witty more banter more sarcastic
fight which is my preferred version
right it's it sounds like marvel was
really unhappy that every spider-man
movie
was so focused on the romance angle and
that they were pretty much love stories
that happen to have a superhero what if
we focus on this element of what if he's
in the middle of class and he hears the
rhino terrorizing downtown like do like
the clark kent thing where he's gonna
have like he's gotta throw up and then
he has to climb out the bathroom window
to go swing downtown and fight crime and
get back before he's tardy or something
so okay there's a validity to that and
and i guess the one other thing is it
does appear we are getting peter parker
again they
peter parker was named in
in the official announcement so the fans
of miles morales i think they're still
going to have to wait
70 something years
well it's a shame because it would have
been the fastest easiest way to break
from all the other stuff that's been
done up to this point we might never see
him out of costume until
the spider-man movie in 2017.
they could cast
a dancer
in the
well certainly do something with the
voice acting in certainly if they tack
something on as as opposed to the post
credits really fast to something like
age of ultron or yeah they'd probably
have to why do you think marvel has done
this now why do you think there was such
a focus to get this done at this point
sony was in a weak enough position in
regards to spider-man that they would
have been prepared to make a deal which
obviously they did marvel doesn't need
spider-man marvel is doing just fine on
their own without spider-man but
if they just waited for sony to continue
to screw it up until they gave up and
just let the rights lapse then what
marvel gets back is a damaged property
and i think
they made the decision that they are
better off getting to borrow a property
that gets buoyed and gets put into a
better position than wait a few years
and get to own wholly a damaged property
that isn't worth what it used to be i
agree that marvel doesn't need
spider-man
right now
because right now they have iron man
captain america and four
and i don't know for how much longer
they have them because contracts are
going to be up and i don't know if
they're going to want to recast right
away and replace them spider-man does
give them some safety net in that in
that people will say
okay i don't know if i would watch
the avengers starring black panther and
ant-man
but if you throw spider-man in the mix
everything just got kind of moved back a
couple of months yeah pretty much i mean
thor ragnarok was originally supposed to
come out in july it's now going to come
out in november yeah uh and thor the
dark world came out in november so
that's not a big change for that but now
black panther doesn't get his solo movie
until after the first part of infinity
war unless
there's a second spider-man movie and
there's already speculation that the
sequel to the next spider-man movie
might be scheduled for 2019 because
marvel's gonna want a quicker turnaround
yeah and that and that's that's
something that hadn't even occurred to
me in the sequel now you know different
people are reading different amounts
into this i think we've sort of had this
discussion before we started the camera
rolling that you're you're reading
into it a little bit more than i am
because i i i see this as while as a fan
it annoys me looking at it from a
strictly business standpoint i think it
really just came down to them looking at
the schedule going
well we got to put it somewhere and they
couldn't wedge it in between
two movies that they already have
planned because then it's bumping up
against them yeah and
or it just puts it in in like a dead
zone you don't release
movies and at that time so i think i
think it was just a matter of
where do we put this where it will still
succeed and it's not going to
cannibalize other stuff and ultimately
that was why everything got shifted up
and bumped i think it was a completely
business driven decision not a we think
spider-man is more important and i and i
get and i i kind of come down a little
bit from that it still leaves a bad
taste in my mouth because they were
willing to stare down warner brothers
and put their captain america threqual
against the first ever on-screen team-up
of superman and batman and they made
warner brothers blank i just wish they
could have said sony you
change your release for this movie if
marvel just left it up to sony and sony
put it in a position where marvel is
somehow competing with it right that
means that either their movies get hurt
because spider-man does better or that
brand gets hurt because their movies do
better i don't they were gonna try and
spin gold out of hay by making by
creating a universe
with sinister six venom and i'm just
gonna call them spider gals and are they
still going to try and do that so far as
we know
yes technically none of this stuff has
been cancelled right which means it
could all still feasibly happen
specifically in the case of the sinister
six movies a really bad idea because
that one specifically was designed to be
coming off of amazing spider-man 2 which
whether or not they're going to
do any kind of real reboot and say that
doesn't count anymore or whether they're
just going to try and not talk about it
you don't want to be tying back to that
thing either way
the venom movie could probably still
work as well as a venom solo movie can
be made to work
at least so far as that does not
automatically tie back to the continuity
that they're now trying to distance
themselves from the sinister six movie
though does if you told me that the
sinister six are going to be the
villains
in the new spider-man movie
i'm pumped that's aces if you still want
to make the sinister six the
protagonists of a movie i still haven't
decided if i'm gonna see suicide squad
and i would see that a thousand times
before i saw the sinister six oh that's
the other thing with the sinister six
movie suicide squad's to be out before
that no matter how quickly they get
stuff pulled together right it was a lot
that happened around spider-man but yet
you know what
even though you know we've expressed our
reservations are concerned for the first
time in a while i am genuinely
interested in what goes on with
spider-man in the movies again i want to
see the next spider-man movie now
and last year i didn't if he does show
up in captain america civil war like i
said i think that starts filming in
april yeah so we'll know when they start
casting
will probably have an idea of how big a
part he can have
and it might be something like
quicksilver's part in
x-men david's past which was a
scene-stealing 10-minute part the first
movie that spider-man shows up in i
don't want to know going into the
theater that he's going to be there i
want him to swing to the scene and i
didn't know it was going to come and i
just go oh
yes
that that is my dream
that would be cool here's hoping nice
because
hope it's a beautiful thing so thank you
very much ryan for joining me and thank
you for joining council of geeks so
until next time this council is
adjourned